foreign
remember that equation
this we covered in the last episode of
the cyber security architecture series
welcome back this was about security
equals prevention plus detection plus
response this is basically what we're
doing in security and we talked about at
the very beginning of the series some
security principles and roles and things
like that tools of the trade then we
moved into prevention and we looked at
each of these different domains identity
and access management an endpoint a
network an application and data and this
is basically that mostly those controls
we put in place are about prevention
trying to prevent someone from breaking
in or doing damage to us then in the
last video if you didn't see that make
sure you check it out in the last video
we really focused on the detection
portion of this the the thing that's up
here that does the monitoring and things
of that sort today we're going to move
on over into once we've discovered that
how do we do response so that's what
we're covering today let's start off
with some of the basics of security
response well remember also I talked
about this diagram where basically the
bad guy comes along and he begins his
attack by doing reconnaissance that's
some number of days where they're
basically casing The Joint they're
looking to see where are the weak spots
where can I get in then the attack
occurs and this is where the damage
begins unfortunately where the attack
occurs and when we're aware of it is
separated by a period of time and that
period of time we call the mean time to
identify and the according to the
ponymon institute's cost of a data
breach survey which I've mentioned
before this is roughly I'm going to make
it approximate roughly 200 days on
average between when the attackers get
in and when we're actually aware of it
mean time to identify 200 days the bad
guy is sitting in your house doing who
knows what before you finally realize
that it's happened that's a big problem
but that's what we covered in the
detection portion then what we're going
to look at today is this next bit here
the mean time to contain how long does
it take for us once we're aware to get
the damage controlled and the bad guys
out and get back to operation and it
turns out this is on the order of 70
days so this is the response portion of
all of this that is clearly not working
well we in fact if you look at the
numbers over the years these numbers
stay roughly the same they don't really
change much so even though we've had
more tooling we've had more
understanding we've had a lot of things
that we tried to do we've not been as an
industry all that terribly effective at
reducing that mean time to identify in
meantime to to contain so what are we
going to do we're going to look at this
this stuff in the response part and see
if we can shrink this 70 days and make
that some number that's shorter than
that so for instance the group that's up
here doing this I talked about this also
in the last video this is what we know
as the sock the security operations
center and it is a centralized team of
people whose job it is to Monitor and
look for across all the different memory
each one of these domains is sending
their information up so that we can see
what's going on we're going to detect
whenever we see anomalous behaviors
alerts things like that where core laid
all of that and then we're going to
respond which again is the focus of what
we're talking about today and that
response business has traditionally been
called incident response or ir and one
of the big things that can cut the cost
of a data breach is having a good
incident response capability in place
traditionally again that's the
terminology we've used it's not wrong
but that's just where we've come from
and what it is is traditionally we've
also made this largely a manual process
it relies on Heroes and experts people
who just happen to have knowledge in
their heads and a gut feel on what to do
and that's how we do this unfortunately
that really doesn't scale well and it's
not necessarily all that repeatable but
their job is to first of all triage that
is to when we get these alarms that come
in we've got to determine is that a real
attack or is this just some noise that's
out there and if it's a real Attack is
it a significant attack or is it not so
significant and which ones because we
never have time to respond to everything
as quickly as we'd like to what's the
order of importance that's the triage
aspect of that looking and figuring out
which patients do we need to see first
that's where that word comes from is in
the health care industry and then once
we've figured out the pecking order then
we're going to do remediation that is
we're going to fix whatever it is we're
going to block we're going to shut
things down we're going to apply
software patches we're going to put in
controls so that we're no longer leaking
data or our systems are able to get back
up and running again
now the more modern approach that we
hear the terminology is sore and I'm
going to do my best to resort to not
using any puns when it comes to a word
like this but it's awfully tempting
anyway soar stands for security
orchestration Automation and response so
it's Automation and orchestration we'll
talk a little bit more about those
coming up and the difference between the
two but just say where this tends to be
traditionally much more manual there the
idea was soar is that we're going to try
to make things as much as possible
automated and that hopefully will help
us reduce the time that it takes to
contain
okay now we've covered the basics of
response now let's take a look in a
little more detail about cases
and investigations because that's the
thing we're going to do next the way
this works is we have an attack remember
over here well now I've depicted it here
and this attack then is going to
generate hopefully some sort of alarm
some sort of event some sort of
indication that we have a problem and
that's going to flow on up here into the
Sim the security information and event
management system which makes up this
detection portion of our security
architecture
now we may also have the Sim feeding in
to an xdr as I mentioned in the previous
video or they may be separate you may
only have xdr or only Sim so I'm just
going to depict it this way for the
purpose of this illustration
what I'd like to do then if this system
is able to identify that we in fact
think this is a problem and someone
needs to go into more detail and
investigate this then one of the things
I want to do is create a case and I'm
going to create that case here
either one of these systems could open
the case automatically in our solar
system the security orchestration
Automation and response system so the
soar is depicted here it's got this case
management as one of its components we
can also use that to modify cases we can
use it to assign cases so I'm going to
assign this case over here to this guy
right here and he's going to be
responsible for looking at all the cases
that are assigned to him and when he
does that one of the things he'll see is
that if we've done a really good job our
xdr or our Sim not only created the case
but also added in these things right
here artifacts indicators of compromise
useful information that the cyber
security analyst is going to use later
when they start trying to do their
investigation so we take that
information and add that into the case
automatically so we enrich the case as
another way of looking at it and that
way this person isn't starting from zero
so they've got some information there's
a problem here's where it started here's
some information I have about it now we
can also with this soar case management
system track and maybe we have an extra
dashboard that allows us to figure out
which cases are open which ones are high
priority who's investigating these and
even reassign these as we need to and
make kinds of adjustments of that sort
now this person is going to need to do
this investigation business they're
going to have to dig in and figure out
what's going on how do they know what to
do do they just start guessing do they
start poking around Well we'd hoped that
they would have a more consistent
repeatable way of figuring out what the
problems are so we'd like to guide their
activities especially if this person is
not very experienced and doesn't know
where to start first so we have these
things called Dynamic playbooks so a
dynamic Playbook is something where we
have gone in in advance and determined
when you see this then run this routine
if you start here and then you go off
and run these two
events maybe their scripts maybe their
particular procedures that a person's
supposed to go through and they do those
and based upon the results of those
things then they might do other things
and depending on the results of that
they do something different that's the
dynamic aspect of this so it's not just
a static standard operating procedure
that spells out you do number one
through ten statically every single time
there may be some of those things but in
fact what we find is that there's a lot
of cases where we have to be more
Dynamic and more flexible and what you
get from this step will depend on what
you want to do in the next steps that's
why it needs to be dynamic and if we're
able to capture that kind of information
in a dynamic Playbook we can guide this
person they don't have to have all of
the expertise that knows everything
about everything but they can follow the
Playbook and let it guide their
activities ultimately they're going to
figure out where the source of the
problem is and we're going to spell out
with the remediation steps they should
take and then they can go back here to
this system and figure out what they
need to do in order to get things
if we're leaking data stop that
hemorrhaging if it's a system that's
down how to bring it back up and protect
it do the remediation that's necessary
with that system
okay now we have gotten an indication
that there was a problem we created a
case opened it in the case management
system and now we have the cyber
security analyst that's going to go off
and investigate this figure out what the
problem is and remediate why wouldn't we
just automate everything well I'm going
to address that in this next business of
automation versus orchestration so think
about this here's the manual approach
and we can think about everything as
being on the Spectrum either it's done
entirely manually or it's done entirely
in an automated way and as much as
possible I'd rather do it this way the
problem is in security we see a lot of
things that sometimes we refer to as
Black Swan events you know swans are
normally white sometimes they're black
it's not impossible it's just more rare
and it's not what we expect and I can
only automate what I've seen before
sometimes we even get insecurity some of
these things we call First of a Kind
events and a first of a kind mind okay
I'm probably going to have to figure
that out manually because I won't have
known how to set up a script to handle
that in advance
but what I'd like to do is as much as
possible do as much of this as I can in
an automated way and for the things I
can't I'll stop somewhere along this
Continuum and we'll do what we call
orchestration think of this as sort of
like semi-automated where we have a
human who is directing the system and
saying okay go I'm going to push this
button it's going to go off and do these
procedures and I'm going to push this
things so think of this also another way
analogy here is the conductor in an
orchestra who is saying okay now I want
the violins to come in here and I want
the drums to exit there and they're
orchestrating what is happening in this
case so orchestration is a step that's
not fully automated but it's in that
direction and the whole goal of this
modern soar capability is to as much as
possible move things in that direction
where it's more automated and less
manual and Orchestra duration is a step
along that way well what are the other
things that we have to do it turns out
if someone attacked us and there was
data that was sensitive to individuals
that then got breached or got
compromised and bad guys got a hold of
it then we might have a responsibility
here for notification this whole
business of breach notification one of
the first things we have to ask is what
kind of data was involved well maybe
there were names
there might be Social Security numbers
if you're in the U.S other types of ID
numbers uh credit card numbers and
things of that sort that's the kind of
information so that's the data I need to
know what kind of data was compromised
then I need to know what geography where
the people whose data was compromised uh
involved so what nation are they in
maybe even what state or region within
that because it turns out we have
different breach notification laws in
different countries in different uh
parts of the world and even within a
country we have different breach
notification rules so for instance one
of these major ones is called the
generalized data protection regulation
gdpr that comes from the European Union
and gdpr specifies very specific very
heavy penalties in fact if you don't
respond within a timely fashion the
penalties for this can be on the order
of 4 percent of worldwide Revenue so
four percent is a huge number for most
organizations or it can be 20 million
euros whichever is greater that's a big
penalty if you don't report in a timely
way when consumers data citizen data has
been compromised and again you might say
but I don't care I am in the U.S or I'm
in Australia I don't have EU uh you know
really hanging over my head
that think again if you've got EU
citizen data you might be subject to EU
rules and penalties so then it's a
question of prosecution but regardless
there are other types of rules in the
U.S each individual state is kind of
coming out with their own sets of rules
with their own set of regulations and so
forth so there are lots of these and
this is what makes it really complicated
to make sure that you have complied with
all of these regulations because there
are so many it's really good to have a
tool point being that would help you
with all of this once I realized as part
of my investigation that there has been
a data breach I'd like to go into the
tool and say here are the types of data
that were compromised here are the
geographies where it was compromised and
here are the different regulatory
requirements that I have to follow and
based upon that the system would come
out and tell me exactly who do I need to
notify and that way I don't end up with
a bunch of this because that gets to be
very expensive
I hope you've enjoyed watching this
series as much as I've enjoyed making it
as I told you at the beginning this is a
condensed version of a course I teach at
a local University so you don't get any
college credit but on the positive side
you also didn't have any homework and
you didn't have to take a final exam so
good news in that regard I hope this
also wedded your appetite and increased
your desire to learn more about cyber
security and that you find this topic as
interesting as I do
what we'd like is to get some feedback
from you if you can add in the comments
what did you learn what was a particular
value to you in this series that helps
us know what kinds of things we should
be doing in future videos so also take a
look
at in the description below and you'll
see a playlist that shows you all 10
videos that were in this series in case
you missed one you don't want to miss
you want to catch all of them so please
go take a look at that and as always
like subscribe and hit the notify bill
so that you're aware of new videos as
they come out
thank you